longback holidaymakers trying to sell
from the port of dover have reported
being stuck in six hour queues to
complete border checks
portal authorities have blamed the
french side accusing them of being
woefully understaffed
well joining me now is doug banister
he's the chief executive of the port of
dover grateful for your time on sky news
this morning so who's to blame
listen first of all i need to say that i
am really very sorry to all those
travelers that have that have headed out
this morning to the truck drivers the
local community in dover we should not
be in this position
we have we have been planning for this
day this morning
for the last several months we have
installed in the port new infrastructure
to be able to handle this we've trained
up more people we have shared traffic
levels by hour for the whole summer with
the appropriate authorities to make
certain that we had enough resource in
place to handle it we had warned that if
we didn't have enough resource in place
this morning starting from about four
o'clock we would be in this situation
and it is highly regrettable that we
find ourselves here
so who's to blame
so
right now we don't know why there was
insufficient resource uh deployed from
police off frontera as people will know
we operate juxtaposed border controls
here in dover and in calais now the good
news is when it works well you clear
french immigration on our side so when
you get to the other side there's no
cues for immigration you just drive
right out and you get on your way but it
is a critical pinch point that we are
feeling right now
what are you hearing from the french
side what have they said to you what
conversation are you having with them
we are having uh conversations at
multiple levels within france you know
our our central government is doing
everything that they can to work with
their french colleagues to make certain
that that we can get people on the
ground now we have had additional
resource sent in this morning and we've
had uh and we're beginning to get the
traffic moving which is good news
however it will take some time for the
backlog to clear
we've got high attention on being able
to get this done and that's what we're
focused on doing right now
uh mr bannister let me just press you on
some of the points there's authorities
that your ports have made
accusing the french side of being
woefully
understaffed is this something that you
agree with
so we had we had shared with them what
our resourcing requirements were and we
had about half the number overnight
okay so so so that is woefully um to use
your words and that is understaffed so
that that is obviously something that
you agree with then you agree that they
have been woefully understaffed
for what we had required for this
morning there was insufficient officers
on the ground ready to do the work and
the processing times through the border
were also much longer than normal
we don't know why
this had happened we will find out but
at this moment in time we're doing
everything that we can to get the
traffic moving and getting people on
their way
well currently people are looking at six
hour queues in which they're they're
stuck sitting there at the moment that's
just
not good enough what is it that you're
doing how long are they going to be
stuck there for is the number likely to
reduce in terms of the hours or are
things set to get worse what what do
they have to look forward to
at this stage because of the backlog
that's been created i can't tell you how
long it's going to take to clear this i
really wish that i could
we what i can tell you is the processing
rates have improved since the early
hours of this morning and the traffic is
is beginning to move through but we've
got a heck of a challenge to get through
it all now this is this is a situation
that we had warned about that if we
didn't have enough resources for for
this day this morning
then we would be faced with a
significant challenge and that is where
we are right now
so you've highlighted the fact that
you're saying that the french side have
been um ill-equipped in terms of staff
numbers what about the uk side then the
numbers how are they looking
well we we have had i can tell you that
our ferry operators have had enough
staff come in they've got it they're
sailing full schedules they're all
prepared uh the the border force teams
that we work with have been excellent
they're all prepared kent uh county
council uh the kent resilience forum
kent police they've got manpower
deployed uh around in the road network
to make certain that it all happens and
and so on our side and indeed we felt
because we were working very closely
with police officer for the last several
months to prepare for this
that we had felt that they were going to
be adequately resourced as well
and you've touched very briefly on that
in terms of working the last several
months to prepare for this day you've
also said um previously that you've been
working with the uk governments um tell
us about some of the conversations that
you've been having to prepare for this
day that you've been having with the uk
government and indeed what the solution
is how do we move forward how do we
prevent people
most of them will be having children
with them sitting in six hour
traffic uh yeah again i am so uh sorry
so disappointed that people who have you
know also planned for this day and when
the when the schools break up and they
want to get away on their holidays to be
to be caught up in this situation is
just so
so tragic it is it is absolutely not
where any of us wanted to be now we've
been we've been talking with uh with
central government with with uh hmrc
with uh the department for transport and
we've been working with them through
this entire process and and uh up until
uh up and well up until this morning
things had all been you know we all knew
what we needed to do and we were all
being prepared to do it and then to be
let down in the way that we have is just
so frustrating
doug banister he's the chief executive
of the port of david thanks for your
time